- [Mark] All right, China.
China where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- [China] Santa Barbara.
- [Mark] Santa Barbara?
- [China] Yeah.
And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
growing up as a kid?
- [China] No I grew up with
dad and then my stepmom.
My sister's mom.
- [Mark] What happened to mom?
- I don't know.
- [Mark] You never knew your mom?
- I knew her, but I didn't, I don't
I don't know what happened to her.
- [Mark] So how was your
childhood with, with your mom,
with your dad?
- I live with my, my stepmom.
- [Mark] Oh stepmom.
- But it was, it was okay.
I couldn't complain.
I had everything I wanted.
- [Mark] So no abuse,
nothing, nothing like that?
- No.
- [Mark] Nothing.
And you, what, what kind of
kid were you in High school?
- Huh?
- [Mark] What kind of kid
were you in High school?
- I went to school, but
like, I didn't stay.
I just, I graduated, but
like I never went to school.
So I don't really know how I
graduated, but I graduated.
- [Mark] Okay.
And you, you left home at what age?
- Sixteen.
- [Mark] And where'd you go at sixteen?
- I first I moved to Oak.
I went to Oakland and then from Oakland
I went to Anaheim.
Anaheim I went to LA
and now I'm on Figaro.
- I live on Figaro.
- [Mark] So you work in Figaro
- I don't, yeah I guess you can say that.
- [Mark] Yeah.
W were you doing this
up in Oakland as well?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So you started
working the street at what age?
- Sixteen.
- [Mark] Sixteen.
And you were doing that with a pimp?
- Yeah.
I guess yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah.
How was that experience?
- Is, me personally is the pimp
or whatever it's it's is bullshit to me.
Like, I guess, cause you
don't have the bright guy
or whatever, but it's bullshit to me.
- [Mark] How did you get started with?
- Through...
I met a guy online and I,
when I moved and I moved
I left my home to go move with him
and he showed me how.
Like he told me like, oh
like you can make money
having sex or whatever.
So I tried it and.
- [Mark] And that, that
relationship lasted how long?
- Not even like probably two months.
- [Mark] Then you went on your own?
- Yeah
- No, he had left me in
Anaheim and then from Anaheim
I took the Greyhound bus to Los Angeles
and in Los Angeles I
met, I met somebody who,
I met another dude at
the Greyhound station
and he introduced me to fig
and I've been working fig.
- [Mark] Ever since?
- Since 2013.
- [Mark] Okay.
And how much money were
you making a night?
- Like probably five, 600 on a good day.
- [Mark] You ever been arrested?
- Yeah.
For prostitution.
- [Mark] How many times?
- Loitering.
Probably for loitering, probably
like two to three times.
- [Mark] And prostitution?
- Is the same thing.
- [Mark] The same thing?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Oh, I see okay.
Do you have kids of your own?
- No.
- [Mark] No kids.
Have you had any bad experiences
with some of the guys
you pick you pick up?
- Yeah.
I've been raped.
I've been kidnapped.
I've been held for ransom.
Um Yeah.
I've been, somebody tried to kill me.
- [Mark] It doesn't discourage
you from doing this?
- Sometimes but if,
that's why I always have
somebody who to come with me to know,
like when I what kind of car I get in.
Not necessarily no pimp
or it can be like a friend
like a homegirl or something.
But I don't, I don't ever go by myself.
- [Mark] Do the girls kind
of look out for each other
on the street?
- Some of them, some of
them, not all of them.
- [Mark] Yeah.
It gets competitive too.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Are drugs a part of your life?
- [Mark] What drugs do you use?
- I smoke meth.
- [Mark] Was that meth or something?
Does your family know you do this?
- What?
- [Mark] Your step-mom or...
- My brother.
- [Mark] Your brother?
Yeah.
I think my dad.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Does it get you down sometimes?
- Sometimes yeah.
- [Mark] Doing this you get depressed?
- Yeah.
Cause it's not like
something that I want to do
but the money comes so it's easy.
- [Mark] Did you have dreams
of doing something else
with your life when you were younger?
- Yeah I wanted to do,
I wanted to be a famous
like cosmetologist or something.
- [Mark] So makeup?
- Yeah. Hair.
- [Mark] And hair.
You're still young. How old are you?
- Twenty five.
- [Mark] Twenty five. So you
can easily still do that.
Are you saving money doing this?
- Yeah,
- [Mark] You are.
That's great.
What do you think the most
misunderstood thing is
about doing this for a living?
What do you think other
people that don't do it maybe?
- That you're having sex for money.
That instead of doing it for
free, why not get paid for it?
It's like a job.
- [Mark] Is that how you view it?
- Well, yeah.
Instead of having sex for free,
having sex for free, why not?
If somebody is willing to pay,
why not get paid for it?
- [Mark] How do you think
working the streets all these
years has changed you?
- Um,
I know I'm not just like
How do you say it?
I'm not, I'm not like shy, I guess.
Like I can talk to, I can have
a conversation with people.
- [Mark] Strangers.
- Yeah.
Because when I was, when I was younger,
I wouldn't even talk to you.
I wouldn't even came in here.
I don't know if that you like
you're stupid and just like what the fuck.
- [Mark] Have you been in love before?
- Have I been in love before?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Damn, yeah.
- [Mark] And what happened?
This, this, this career
get in the way of that?
- No, actually I'm still with the person
I fell in love with.
It's been a year.
- [Mark] Okay.
Does this relate?
Does this lifestyle
get in the way of romantic relationships?
- Sometimes I think so.
If the person that you're with
doesn't like they accept it
but they don't accept that.
They say they accept it, but
then they really feel some type
of way about you doing it.
- [Mark] All right.
What advice would you give
to a young girl who's
considering doing this?
- Damn.
I wouldn't, I wouldn't advise it.
Go to school, get a job, a regular job.
I wouldn't advise it to nobody.
- [Mark] Yeah.
All right, China.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] And good luck with
whatever you do from here.
- Okay.
- [Mark] You're still young.